The last tip and I'm all ears.
How do we organize the fridge The Home Edit way?
Alright.
We'll take a look at it.
Okay.
So you can see.
Alright, alright, Drew.
Now that is a beauty.
(audience applauding)
Yep, she is a beauty.
That's way better than my game.
Okay, how do I bring her home?
Alright, okay, so the very first thing
you should implement if you wanna have
an organized fridge are clear bins.
It is really helpful to divide, categorize,
you know exactly what you have,
when you're running low on something, you can see it all
and it's not just like a big mishmash.
Right, the second thing we would say
is with the clear bins, especially these,
you're able to stack them,
so you're able to take advantage of the vertical space,
which otherwise goes unused.
In the fridge, you have such limited space,
that you wanna use every inch wherever you can.
This is truly maximizing the height.
And we love a label, we love a label with everything
and by the way, a rainbow organizing system is also a label.
It's a mechanism of finding what you need
and where to put it back
and these labels are actual stickers that we put on.
But it's really helpful for everyone in the family
to kind of, you know, identify where things go.
It's really a lot harder for your spouse, your partner
or a roommate to put things in the wrong area,
if you have marked it correctly.
Is it weird that I now find the fridge
sexier than the bedroom?
(all laughing)
No.
Actually I don't think so.
I am literally like this so hot.
(all laughing)
Like it's my true, honest feelings.
Now, the other night I'm staring at my phone
and I get a text from our dear friend, Anthony Soohoo.
Oh!
Who is one of the heads of Walmart
and you guys are crushing it there right now.
Thank you so much,
it's a dream, it's a dream come true.
So now that we can go get The Home Edit at Walmart,
like thank you.
We're gonna organize
all of the beautiful items in our Home Edits.
(audience applauding)
Yes, yes.
Clea and Joanna, I love you guys so much.
Don't forget to catch season two
of "Get Organized with the Home Edit" streaming on Netflix.
Now I am proud to be on one of their episodes.
Thank you for having me, you guys.
We're so happy.
I love you.
(melodic upbeat music)